Tim pitchell knows procrastination
better than anyone over the course of
two decades he has published over 25
papers on the subject and his
procrastination research group at
Carlton University in Canada is arguably
the world's most influential source of
scientific insight into why we put
things off it has rubbed off on him I
don't almost ever procrastinate he told
me I may post a child for saying that
once you learn some things about
procrastination you can reduce it if you
want to so what's the trick I asked him
what's the one piece of advice you give
to people to help them overcome
procrastination his response was
surprising pitchell told me that
whenever he finds himself
procrastinating from anything he simply
asks himself what's the next action step
for instance when he knows he's
procrastinating from doing yoga his next
action step is to roll out his yoga mat
and stand on it that's it this approach
sounds suspiciously simple but it works
pitch's method is a way of turning the
abstract bias to action into a concrete
Next
Step